je lui demande de faire face à vos
responsabilités bien sûr vous avez
acheté il ya quatre ans vous deviez
rénové vous avez laissé le bien courir
aux gens non habités comme ça j'ai
aujourd'hui non monsieur nous avons des
photos
aujourd'hui on était quand aujourd'hui
nantes et dans l'ain jour nuit vous êtes
un danger pour vos voisins
il est très en colère le maire de sel 1
face aux propriétaires d'une maison dont
le toit vient de s'écrouler
cas typique on achète et on n'a pas
l'argent pour restaurer plus tordus
celui qui devient propriétaire d'un
immeuble ne loue pas volontairement les
appartements et ainsi profite de la
défiscalisation
il laisse tomber en ruines sont bien
tout simplement parce qu'à une
disposition fiscale qui lui permet de
défalquer les loyers qu'ils ne touchent
pas on en a deux ou trois comme ça donc
on va aller vers de la coercition c'est
à dire que on lui propose des aides pour
rénover s'il ne veut pas rénové nous
allons aller jusqu'à l'expropriation et
oui gilles beder et quelquefois obligé
de prendre des décisions très
impopulaire il a même fermé une église
l'église saint-maurice qui a des
moellons qui ont commencé à tomber du
plafond et qui aurait pu être dangereux
pour les fidèles donc je nous avons
décidé de fermer cette église pour des
raisons de sécurité faut-il resterez
saint maurice d'ailleurs quel bâtiment
gardé lesquels démolir et surtout en
fonction de quels critères
cruel dilemme
aujourd'hui quand on traverse salins on
voit surtout ses façades grises et
bâtiments en piteux état
ces magasins fermés et pourtant
quatre mille ans avant jésus-christ le
sel est déjà exploité ici
ce gisement le plus important d'europe
fait la fortune de la ville durant
plusieurs siècles
un signe qui ne trompe pas salle 1 p
énormément d'impôts ce sera le poumon
économique de la province de du comté de
bourgogne puisque la ville de sanaa
contribuer pour moitié à la contribution
générale de la franche-comté voyage à
une gigantesque
[Musique]
17 concret gassion religieuses vivent
dans cette ville fortifiée
même les templiers ils possèdent leur
chapelle avec à sa tête jacques de molay
il deviendra le dernier grand maître et
mourra sur le bûcher
[Musique]
au xviie siècle les salinois érige notre
dame libératrice en remerciement à la
vierge pour les avoir protégés des
mercenaires du roi de france
tout ça là raconte un passé prestigieux
les églises des fontaines des hôtels
particuliers avec des jardins
magnifiques même certains escaliers
dette du moyen-âge
un chantier de jeunes les restaure alors
bonjour voilà nos éléments
et c'est les mêmes travailleurs salaire
d'avant c'est superbe
et là vous imaginez pas le bonheur que
vous allez rendre aux salines war par
leurs escaliers mythique et on s'était
engagés à le restaurer et je pense qu'en
deux ou trois fois on va peut être y
arriver
oui il faudra bien plusieurs étés pour
finir cette restauration
vous vous promenez dans salins est ce
que vous voyez la beauté des bâtiments
où le coût que cela représente pour la
municipalité et les deux le patrimoine
est à la fois une charge et surtout une
grande chance à condition de prendre le
problème à bras le corps de l'étaler
dans le temps parce que nous n'avons
évidemment pas forcément les moyens de
tout faire tout de suite
mais oui pour moi le patrimoine c'est
une porte d'entrée de revitalisation
c'est ce que j'ai demandé à mes services
ce chiffre est moins ce qu'il faut
dépenser pour tout refaire
nous arrivons entre 64 et 70 millions
d'euros
[Musique]
concernant les trois églises une seule
certitude notre dame libératrice sera
rénové coup quatre cent mille euros
puis le conseil municipal et les
paroissiens devront choisir entre deux
bâtiments restaurés à maurice pour 2
millions d'euros ou sainte anne à toile
pour un million faire des choix toujours
cruel dilemme
exemple avec ce pâté de maison à
réhabiliter magali bresson étudiante en
architecture présente son étude
après 18 mois de travail à deux membres
du conseil municipal
j'ai surtout retenu une phrase dans
l'habitant rencontré pas très loin d'ici
dans la rue de la liberté et qui disait
pour parler de sa land extérieur ses
anciennes maisons elle paye pas de mine
mais à l'intérieur on a des pépites
on s'arrêtait d'élan questionnement sur
qu'est-ce qu'on conserve qu'est-ce qu'on
modifie qu'est ce qu'on va voilà mettre
en évidence sa proposition des
appartements duplex une supérette en
élargissant la rue et donc en détruisant
les façades
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit bien
nécessaire de tout démolir vous trouvez
c'est un peu trop radicales comme au
projet oui c'est ma grosse émission
c'est notre conception vue n'ont pas
forcément de génération ii peut-être de
sensibilité au patrimoine
là par exemple sacrifier cette belle
ensemble de façade
je ne le ferai pas ici c'est arcade
elles sont 15e ou 16e et donc c'est il y
a des choses des pépites aussi oui
qu'ils font sans ce qu'ils font aussi
partie de l'identité de will et rue de
salomon nature c'est de leur target ou
soient un comme ça beaucoup de réflexion
et d'argent seront encore nécessaires
pour que ce projet se concrétise enfin
faire du patrimoine à tous ces trois
professionnels du tourisme ont joué
cette carte
l'impératrice eugénie les tous de
napoléon iii venait prendre les eaux à
salins le gérant de l'hôtel des bains à
restaurer la pièce où elle recevait elle
s'arrête dépotoir exact trois jeux c'est
par amour aussi du patrimoine on peut
pas laisser une salle comme celui ci
dans cet état dans l'état où elle était
du moins
robert n'était à craquer lui pour le
fort saint-andré de vauban dans ce lieu
et l'accueil séminaires et mariage
enfant j'étais passionné par louis xiv
par toute l'histoire de france
l'histoire de france en général donc dès
qu'on rentre dans un même bâtiment faux
bond on se dit waouh
j'ai une chance et non à quoi donc voilà
on réalise ce rêve de rentrer presque un
petit peu dans l'histoire
cette ancienne série a été transformé en
maison doute après un premier raid et
d'exploitation son propriétaire est ravi
que c'était tellement beau qu'on avait
envie de montrer aux gens ce qui avait
été fait c'était tellement dommage que
cette partie de l'histoire disparaissent
à cause de travaux qu'on n'aurait pas
fait que là on est vraiment tombé
amoureux et quand on s'y sent bien on
sent que c'est comme si les gens ils
étaient encore là qui travaillaient avec
notre part estimé me défrise le salon et
jenny le fort saint-andré l'ancienne
scierie ont trouvé un équilibre entre
passé et modernité
aujourd'hui ces lieux vivent une
nouvelle existence
des exemples à suivre le patrimoine doit
être entretenu de doit être sur mes yeux
bien sûr entretenu habitées on peut
aussi l'adapter l'art de vivre
d'aujourd'hui ce qui est important et
puis tout en conservant l'essentiel de
la richesse patrimoniale vous voulez pas
en faire un musée de sedin en couleurs
ce serait une catastrophe si on en
faisait le musée il faut justement que
le patrimoine soit vivant
au pied du mur mais forte de son passé
glorieux
c'est l'un veut croire en sa renaissance
[Musique]